PROFESSOR: Let me begin by
introducing the subject.
The subject is resonances.
And we have seen,
actually, a little bit
of this in the
resonant transmission
of the Ramsauer-Townsend effect.
Because of a
resonance phenomenon
within the square well
obstacle, somehow,
for some particular frequencies,
for some particular energies,
the particles were able to
zoom by without experiencing
any reflection, whatsoever.
So let's begin the
subject of resonances
by asking a question.
If you have the usual potential,
the short range potential,
which means, that for some
distance, R, greater than 0,
the potential is 0.
Here we put a barrier,
and over there
could be anything,
some potential.
We've computed some-- this
concept of time delay,
there's a formula
for the time delay.
In fact, it was given by 2 h
bar d delta dE, the time delay,
2 h bar d delta dE.
And we discussed that this
time delay can be positive
or it can be negative.
If it's positive, it
really means a time delay.
You send in a wave packet.
And it takes time to come
back, more time than it
would have taken if there
had been no potential.
You see, the time delay,
you have a packet coming
in from time minus infinity.
And then it bounces back
a time equal infinity.
But nevertheless, you
compare that with a situation
in which there's no potential.
And you see that there
is some time delay.
If you time the wave packet
to reach at time equals 0,
here, it will not reach back
to where you were by time--
by whatever time-- suppose
you have the wave packet here
at t equal minus 10, then
it goes here, and it delays,
and at t equal 10, the
packet has not reached,
there is a time delay,
a positive time delay.
A negative time delay
is the opposite.
The packet arrives
a little earlier.
And the question
I want to ask you,
if you have a
negative time delay,
can it be arbitrarily large.
Well, if you send
in a wave packet,
it may find an infinite wall
here, and then may bounce,
and then yes, it
comes back earlier
than you expected, because
the free packet would
have gone here and back.
But you wouldn't expect it
to be able to come earlier
than if there was an
infinite wall here,
because there is no
nor an infinite wall here.
So it's just not going to
bounce before it reaches here.
The best it can do is
bounce when it reaches here.
So you should not expect,
and this, sometimes,
will [INAUDIBLE],
there is nothing
that can make it bounce
until you reach here.
So you cannot expect that the
time advance is larger as if it
would have bounced before
reaching the obstacle,
whatsoever.
So this is important.
We cannot have a negative time
delay that this infinitely
large.
So, in fact, the time delay
as, we're right in here,
should be greater than
the total travel distance
that you may save.
If you bounce here, you
would save 2R over v.
And you must be greater than
that negative number, which
is the total travel
time that it would take
to go back and forth, here.
So we can do a little
arithmetic, here.
This is equal to 2 h bar d
delta dk, and here, dE dk.
This is still greater than or
equal than minus 2R over v.
And I want to put a sim, because
our argument is not completely
rigorous as to what's
happening when it reaches here.
It seems very
plausible classically,
but there's a bit
of a correction
if you do it exactly.
So it's not an exact
inequality we're deriving.
And what is the E dk is
h bar times the velocity.
Remember, dE dk, you
are differentiating
h squared k squared over 2m.
And you get h bar
times hk over m.
So therefore, this is
h bar and the velocity.
And the h bars cancel.
The velocities cancel.
Between these two
sides, the 2s cancel.
And you'll get that d delta dk
must be greater than or equal,
approximately, to R.
And that's sometimes
called Wigner's condition
on scattering.
And it basically is the
idea that the time delay,
the time advance
cannot be too large.
OK, so now we can ask
the second question.
How about the time
delay, a true time delay,
can it be very large?
Can it be arbitrarily large?
Suppose we have a
barrier of this form.
And now you send a particle
with a little bit higher energy
here.
Now, this particle
is going to have
very little kinetic energy.
So it's going to travel quite
slowly here, and go back.
And this time, it's going to
delay quite a bit, probably.
But the problem is, if you
create-- there's nothing
very peculiar about this,
if you go a little lower,
than you're advanced, and then
suddenly, it gets delayed.
It's not that evident, but
the phenomenon of resonance
is precisely what we get when
we, sort of, trap the particle.
And then we make it be, as far
as it seems, arbitrarily large,
if you design a well properly.
But the thing that
we have to design,
the example of what
we're going to design,
is different from all the
things I've drawn so far.
It's the following way,
this is just an example.
I have this zero
line of the energy.
This is v of x.
This is x.
And then I put an
attractive potential here.
And here is minus v0.
And then I put a
barrier here with a v1.
So what I'm going to
aim at is, you see,
if v1 will be extremely
large, there will be--
well, if v0 is
extremely large, then
begin there would be
bound states here,
but these are not
scattering states.
On the other hand, if v1
will also be infinite,
you would have
bound states here,
but they could not escape.
So certainly, if I
combine these two,
I put a v0 and
maybe a larger v1,
I can almost create
bound states here.
But they're not
really bound states,
because they can leak out and
produce scattering states.
But these are going
to be resonances.
This part and this,
this being a attractive,
trying to keep the particle
in, and this being a barrier,
can combine to produce a
state that gets trapped here,
and stays a very long, time,
will have a very long time
delay.
And that's the
phenomenon of resonances.
We need to trap that
particle, somehow.
And we're going to see now
the details of how this works,
and what the properties are.
Now, it's very interesting
that actually, these resonances
occur at some
particular energies.
And they have
different properties.
But we can identify
energies of resonances.
And these are not bound states.
They're just resonances.
They eventually escape.
And they're not normalizable,
really, but in some ways
they behave as bound
states for awhile.
They stay there for a
while and do nice things.
So let's set this off.
Now we're going to
spare you a little bit
of these calculations,
because the important thing is
that you know how to set it
up, and if you get an answer,
you know how to plot it,
how to get the units out,
how to try to understand it.
So that's what
we're going to do.
I'm going to put an
energy here, an energy, E.
And I'm going to receive
E to be less than v1
and greater than 0.
I don't expect true
resonances beyond,
because the particle
just bounces out.
It doesn't get trapped.
The phenomenon of resonance is a
little more intricate than just
having a long time delay.
There's more that has to happen.
Another thing that
will happen, is
if the particle spends
a lot of time here,
you would find, in this
spirit of resonance,
that the amplitude
of the wave function
here is going to be very big.
So you will scan the
energy and the amplitude.
It will be normal,
normal, normal.
And suddenly for some
energy it becomes very big.
And we're going to do that.
The way I'm going to develop
that, we're going to calculate
this, plot these things.
And then we are going
to ask whether there
is a mathematical condition
that picks resonances.
Well, how do I, if I want
to explain to somebody in 30
seconds where are
the resonances,
how do you calculate them, you
cannot tell that somebody, OK,
calculate it for all
energies, do all the plots,
and see some peak in some
thing, and this is a resonance.
This is what we're going
to do to begin with,
but then we'll get
more sophisticated.
So let's put k in.
So let's call this k prime,
the wave number in this area.
Kappa here, because it's
a forbidden region, and k
over here, as usual.
So k squared is 2mE
over h bar squared.
K prime squared is equal to
2m, the total kinetic energy
is E plus v0, over h squared.
And kappa squared is again,
similar formula, but this time
is the energy differential
between v1 and E,
so 2m v1 minus E over h squared.
All of these three
numbers are positive.
And they are the
relevant constants
to write wave functions.
So we have to write
a wave function.
And I'm going to
write a wave function
because it takes
a little tinkering
to do it in an efficient way.
There is one that you
don't have to think,
you just have to remember.
It's the one outside.
It's the universal
formula, e to the i delta
sine kx plus delta is valid
for for x greater than R.
This one we derived at the
beginning of our analysis
of scattering.
How about the other region.
Oops, I should have
put letters here.
These are a and 2a
they are positions.
And therefore,
it's not R in here.
Well, it's R, it's the range of
the potential, but here is 2a.
How about the other one?
In this region, it's
kind of simple again.
The wave function has to
vanish here, has to be
sines or cosines of k prime.
So it has to be a sine
function of k prime.
And since we don't put an
extra constant in here,
we kind of put an
there must be a constant
here, A sine of k prime x.
And that must be for
x between 0 and a.
We used k prime, the
wave from over there.
And there is A. And what we
were saying about resonances,
is that, well, A
may depend on k.
And when you have
a resonance, A is
going to [INAUDIBLE], presumably
because the particle spends
a long time inside the well.
And now I have to
write this one in here.
And this is the
one that, you can
do it, do a little bit more
work, or do it kind of,
efficiently.
In that region we
have exponentials,
like we have e to the kappa
x and e to the minus kappa x.
Or I may want to have sinh
of kappa x and cosh of kappa
x to write my solutions.
But I actually don't
want either of them
too much, because I
would like to write
an answer that almost imposes
continuity in a nice way.
So I could use sinh of kappa
x minus a and cosh of kappa x
minus a.
These are all solutions.
You can choose
whichever pair you want.
So for example, if I want
to implement continuity
with this thing,
this wave function,
I want to write
something that I don't
have to write another
equation for continuity.
So I will write A
sine of k prime a--
so far, this wave
function, if x equal a,
coincides with this one.
But this is no wave function
yet, not with an x dependence,
so I have to put more.
But then, I know that cosh
is 1 for x equals zero.
So I put here a cosh
kappa x minus a.
And now this is a solution that
matches that one at x equals a.
At x equal a, the cosh
becomes 1 and matches.
But this kind of need
a complete solution.
It's not general enough.
So you have to put a B
sinh of kappa x minus a.
And this won't ruin the
matching, because at x equal a,
that second term vanishes.
So we're still
matching well there.
And Well matching
here is non-trivial
when I impose some conditions.
So you still have to match
derivatives and do a little bit
of work but not too much work.